شكرًا
لك ، لقد تحدثت الدبابات إلى انسحاب روسي متسرع
حيث اجتاحت القوات الأوكرانية
شرقًا خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
برفع العلم منتصرًا فوق كوبيانسك يوم
السبت ، وفرت قوات الشرطة المحلية
لشبكة CNN وصولاً حصريًا إلى بلدة رئيسية
يُفترض الآن أن تكون تحت السيطرة الأوكرانية ،
وما زلنا نشعر بعدم الارتياح لأن  لقد تم
قصفنا لمدة أربعة أيام متتالية يقول
التابعين ولا شيء بالتأكيد حتى الآن
أصبح أكثر وضوحًا عندما
توجهنا إلى طائرات الهليكوبتر الكوبية.
بجانب سيارتنا ، وصلنا سيارتنا المصفحة
إلى منطقة كوبيانغ على أمل الوصول
إلى هذا العلم لنرى المكان الذي تم
زرعه فيه بالأمس فقط ، لكن كما
ترون بعد ظهر يوم الأحد ، لا يزال
هذا المشهد من بعض القتال العنيف الجميل
الذي سنسمعه  صوت
نيران المدفعية الخارجة كان
صوت
اصابتين دخلتين استهدفتا سيارتنا بشكل مباشر بينما
حان وقت الشرطي للعودة إلى ما
كنا نشترك فيه.  أرى تلك الأجزاء من
منطقة هاركي الخاضعة للسيطرة الأوكرانية بالكامل
حيث بعد ستة أشهر من الاحتلال ،
يعرف المحققون الأوكرانيون
جيدًا ما سيجدونه بعد الجزار
والبورديانكا التي كانت تحت
السيطرة الروسية لمدة شهر واحد فقط في الواقع
نعم وفقًا لمعلوماتنا
يسجلون جرائم حرب في كل
قرية تقريبًا ، كما
يقول ، جثة أحد المدنيين اللذين
قُتلا في أواخر فبراير / شباط
، ضحية مبكرة للغزو ،
وأدلة الآن على ما كلفته ستة أشهر من
الاحتلال الروسي في
أوكرانيا.